"Uncatchable", Alexandr Zhelanov
...
-Osvalde Lewat,
quel est le principal préjugé
dont souffre l'Afrique ?
-Cela dépend
de qui porte ce préjugé.
Si on considère
que c'est un préjugé
qui est forgé en Occident,
on va dire que, sans doute,
c'est considéré que
l'Afrique a un train de retard,
qu'elle n'a pas pris
la marche du monde.
Il y a un procès en arriération
qui lui est fait.
-C'est vrai ?
-Bien sûr.
On entend souvent dire
beaucoup de choses,
en général très négatives.
C'est un pays...
C'est un continent
qui est... Lapsus !
qui est sous-développé,
les populations sont pas
entrées dans l'histoire.
Mais ce qui m'interpelle,
moi, aujourd'hui,
c'est lorsqu'on voit les sociétés
qui sont dites développées,
ces sociétés capitalistes
qui ont épuisé la planète,
dans une économie extractiviste,
on s'interroge,
enfin, moi, je m'interroge
savoir au fond qui est
moins développé que qui.
L'Afrique aujourd'hui est
en train de repenser
un modèle de développement
propre, qui soit endogène,
qui soit...
-Moins dépendant, je dirais,
de l'Occident, c'est ça ?
C'est...
-Moins dépendant
de l'Occident aussi, bien sûr,
mais surtout
qui ne soit plus arrimé
à un cahier des charges
qui lui avait été dicté,
indiqué depuis toujours.
L'Afrique s'est
quand même construite
dans le regard des autres,
avec des injonctions
qui lui ont été imposées
pendant plusieurs décennies,
voire depuis la colonisation.
Et aujourd'hui, elle est en train
d'essayer de se réinventer
en adaptant ses besoins
aux réalités des populations
et non pas en se soumettant
à des desiderata
étrangers, occidentaux.
-Extérieurs. Vous dites
qu'il y a une espèce
de critique récurrente,
assez négative sur l'Afrique.
Or on entend aussi un peu
le contraire en disant : l'Afrique,
c'est le continent de demain, celui
où il y a toutes les richesses
et le continent de l'avenir.
On l'entend aussi.
-Oui, on entend ça,
mais en même temps,
ça veut dire qu'en ce moment,
si c'est le continent de l'avenir,
cela indique en creux que,
pour le moment,
l'Afrique n'est pas.
Aujourd'hui, on nie son existence
telle qu'elle est,
sa manière
d'être présente au monde.
Et en réalité,
on se projette
sans cesse et
on se projette aussi
comme un continent où il n'y aurait
pas de populations,
un continent
qui serait simplement
un vivier de ressources
qu'on pourrait extraire.
-L'Afrique n'est pas
une, elle est multiple,
il y a plusieurs Afrique.
Si on est au Cap,
on n'est pas à Alger.
Si on est à Abidjan,
on n'est pas à Djibouti.
Elle est très différente,
cette Afrique, non ?
-Bien sûr.
C'est une Afrique diversifiée,
il y a des cultures différentes,
des populations,
un rapport au monde qui,
même si on peut considérer
de façon globale
et un peu rapide, est le même,
il y a beaucoup de singularités.
Je viens du Cameroun.
-On va parler du Cameroun.
-Et parfois,
l'altérité pour moi à certains
moments, c'est le Sénégalais,
plutôt que même quelqu'un...
l'Amérindien, par exemple.
-D'accord.
-Donc, oui,
je crois aujourd'hui,
on le dit de plus en plus,
mais on ne le dit pas assez,
que l'Afrique, ce n'est pas
un tout uniforme, compact,
où chacun peut déverser
ses propres projections
et ses fantasmes.
-Alors, 3e chose, vous dites,
elle veut exister
par elle-même, cette Afrique,
ou ces Afrique, qu'elle a
une singularité, une richesse,
qui n'est pas uniquement
une richesse du sous-sol,
c'est qu'elle a une richesse
artistique incroyable.
Quand vous regardez un petit peu
toutes les influences
portées par l'Afrique,
toutes les musiques du monde,
dans l'art culinaire,
en littérature,
vous qui êtes écrivain,
qui êtes romancière,
un livre qui a fait beaucoup parler
de lui il y a pas très longtemps,
"Les Aquatiques",
il y a une profusion d'écrivains
sur le continent africain,
dont on disait
que c'était
le continent de l'oralité.
-Oui. Je pense simplement
que ces écrivains-là,
ces talents ont toujours existé.
Peut-être que, simplement,
c'est une ère qui a changé
et les gens s'intéressent
de plus en plus
à ce qui se produit
sur le continent.
Le premier livre
a été écrit en Afrique
par Thomas Mofolo,
un Sud-Africain, en 1907.
Et depuis, la production
africaine n'a cessé
d'être profuse, abondante.
Simplement, il y avait ce préjugé
dont vous parliez dès le départ,
qui était : c'est
le continent de l'oralité,
le continent des ténèbres et
surtout, ce rapport de subalterne
qui a été institué
avec la colonisation faisait que,
de l'Afrique,
on n'attendait pas grand-chose.
Et aujourd'hui, je crois
que les gens ont commencé,
le monde, l'Occident a commencé
à réviser ce regard-là.
Mais aussi parce que des Africains
s'élèvent aujourd'hui,
que des voix se font entendre
et que des discours sont prononcés
par les Africains
et non pas seulement
au nom des Africains.
-Avec l'émergence
d'une classe moyenne ?
-Oui, tout à fait.
-C'est une réalité ?
-Oui, elle est de plus
en plus prépondérante.
-Un discours a fait
beaucoup de bruit en France
et en Afrique, en Afrique,
beaucoup, beaucoup,
c'est le discours
de Nicolas Sarkozy en 2007.
A peine élu d'ailleurs.
Il va à Dakar
et il dit que le problème
de l'Afrique est que l'homme
africain n'est pas rentré
dans l'histoire.
*-Le 26 juillet
*2007, ce jour-là,
*Nicolas Sarkozy déclenchait
la polémique avec cette phrase :
*-Le drame de l'Afrique,
c'est que l'homme africain
*n'est pas assez entré
dans l'histoire.
-Alors, c'est un discours qui a été
écrit par Henri Guaino, qui est
un gaulliste de la 1re heure et
c'est un discours qui a des accents
parfois un peu infantiles
pour l'Afrique.
Comment vous l'avez reçu,
ce discours ?
-Euh... J'ai été heurtée
comme beaucoup d'Africains
sur le continent,
d'Africains de la diaspora
à travers le monde.
On a été heurtés et en même temps,
j'en ai ri. J'en ai ri,
parce que ça traduisait
quand même l'ignorance
d'un président
de la République française.
Tenir de tels propos
lorsqu'on sait que, par exemple,
la charte du Mandé, de Kouroukan
Fouga, date du 13e siècle,
alors que la Déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen
en France date du 18e siècle...
-Que dit cette charte ?
-Cette charte, elle...
Elle souligne la primauté
de la vie sur le reste.
Elle indique qu'il n'y a pas
de discrimination possible
entre les vies, qu'il n'y a pas
une vie plus ancienne, une vie
plus jeune et que tous les hommes
sont égaux. Et ça, au 13e siècle.
Il y a eu de grands empires
en Afrique, des royaumes.
Je ne vais pas
revenir sur tout cela.
D'entendre un président français
s'exprimer ainsi,
c'était une très grande légèreté
et puis une faute.
-Ca a considérablement attaqué
sa réputation en Afrique ou...
Parce qu'il y avait
quand même...
Les présidents français ont
toujours été plutôt bien accueillis
en Afrique, en général.
-A la télé, oui.
Alors, oui,
les présidents français
bénéficiaient d'un crédit plutôt
positif pendant plusieurs années,
notamment parce que c'était aussi
dans des pays
qui étaient gérés
de manière assez ferme
par des pouvoirs autocratiques.
Donc, dans la société civile,
chez les intellectuels,
c'était souvent
un accueil plutôt contrasté
et un regard assez critique.
-C'est pas pour ça que
la population adhérait, c'est ça ?
-La population adhérait en général
de façon plutôt obligatoire.
-C'est ça.
-Je me rappelle quand j'étais jeune
et à l'école primaire,
déjà, quand un président français
arrivait, on fermait les classes,
on barrait les routes et il fallait
se tenir au bord de la route
et applaudir et sourire.
On me demandait de la faire,
y compris au lycée.
A ce moment-là, je n'avais
pas encore le sens du recul,
la distance,
pour mesurer ce qui se jouait.
Je pense qu'on peut difficilement
dire avec le recul aujourd'hui
que c'était une adhésion franche,
parce que ces populations étaient
dans un suivisme,
un suivisme d'Etat.
-Vous connaissez ce proverbe ?
Il lit.
...
-C'est un proverbe
qui est assez juste,
qui revient
une fois de plus
sur la manière
dont les colonisés,
les ex-colonisés ont été
présentés au monde,
sur des discours
qui se sont tenus sur eux,
la manière
dont ils ont été objectivés
par les anthropologues,
les ethnologues,
et une parole qui leur a été
confisquée pendant longtemps.
C'est pour ça que moi, par exemple,
dans ma démarche artistique,
il est important que je raconte
les histoires de l'Afrique
et que moi comme d'autres,
on raconte
nos histoires.
-Vous êtes africaine, c'est à vous
de raconter votre histoire.
-Oui, pas seulement à moi,
mais c'est à moi aussi.
Cela a été empêché
pendant très longtemps.
Les Africains écoutaient
des discours
qui étaient tenus sur eux
et quelque part, ils ont construit
leur subjectivité
à travers ces discours.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est de moins en moins possible,
puisque ces voix minorées se
faisaient de plus en plus entendre,
et quand elles se faisaient
entendre, ce n'était pas
tout à fait la même manière
que lorsqu'on parlait d'elles.
Et je crois qu'on ne peut
reconstruire son identité,
la confiance en soi
que lorsqu'on a des repères,
des repères
qui vous sont transmis
par le passé, par les aînés,
par une société.
En Afrique, au Cameroun notamment,
il y a cette phrase-là
qu'on entend souvent
et avec laquelle j'ai grandi,
qui est : lorsque quelqu'un
est raffiné, éduqué ou a
une belle réussite, on dit de lui
"c'est un vrai Blanc".
Je ne sais pas
si vous vous rendez compte en creux
de ce que ça dit.
L'horizon à atteindre,
c'est être blanc.
L'étalon, le mètre étalon
du succès,
de la beauté, de la réussite...
-C'est l'Occidental.
-C'est
l'Occidental et, en creux,
comme ça dénie,
ça disqualifie
les Noirs, les Africains.
-On l'entend encore,
cette expression ?
-Oui, j'ai grandi avec,
on l'entend encore.
Combien de fois je me suis fait
traitée de "vraie Blanche"
comme un compliment, ce qui
pour moi est une insulte extrême.
Pas parce que j'ai un problème
à être traitée de Blanche,
mais parce que c'est encore
une survivance
de l'héritage colonial
où ce qui était blanc
était forcément bon
et paré de toutes les vertus
et qualités.
-C'est peut-être en train
de changer, même dans l'approche
que les Occidentaux,
en tous les cas en France, ont de
l'Afrique. Et on l'a vu récemment,
avec le président de la République
qui a accueilli un sommet.
Il y avait une tradition en France,
les sommets France-Afrique.
Le premier à l'avoir organisé
d'ailleurs est
le président Giscard d'Estaing
et il n'y avait
que les chefs d'Etat.
Et là, en 2021, le président
de la République a décidé
que ce sommet aurait
lieu à Montpellier
et que ce sommet, ce serait
lui et puis son cabinet,
mais avec la société
civile africaine.
Et donc,
il y a des intellectuels,
des acteurs de la société
civile africaine,
qui venaient
de partout en Afrique,
qui sont venus dialoguer avec lui.
Et là, ils lui ont fait...
Ils n'ont pas ménagé
leurs critiques.
Vous avez suivi ce sommet ?
-Bien sûr.
-C'était nouveau.
-Bien sûr, c'était nouveau
et c'était une initiative
qui, sur le principe,
était intéressante.
Ca faisait suite au discours
de Ouagadougou de novembre 2017.
Le président Macron avait décidé
de réinventer
la relation non pas France-Afrique,
mais Afrique-France.
Je voulais quand même préciser,
même quand on dit France-Afrique,
c'est France et le pré carré
français en Afrique,
puisque ça aussi...
C'est pas toute l'Afrique.
Il faut le préciser.
Donc, maintenant,
qu'un président français décide
de ne plus faire de sommet
avec des chefs d'Etat,
mais plutôt avec une société civile
et une jeunesse africaine,
pourquoi pas, mais ça interroge.
-Pourquoi ?
-Cette société civile-là,
ses représentants ont été choisis
par les ambassades de France dans
les pays où ils ont été invités.
Alors, sur quels critères ?
Comment s'est opéré le choix ?
Je ne sais pas.
Et je crois aussi que,
pour l'iconographie, de voir, même
dans une démarche de révolution
et de changement
ou de rééquilibrage
de ces relations-là,
de voir un président tout seul
face à une jeunesse d'un continent,
pour moi, je trouve
que ça pose problème.
Ca pose problème, car ce n'est pas
réversible comme situation.
J'imagine très mal
un président africain...
-Recevoir la société civile
française !
-Même pas française, européenne.
-Oui, pardon.
-Dans une ville africaine.
-Yaoundé, Abidjan.
-Donc, ça, c'est encore
un signe, c'était une image
de verticalité,
d'asymétrie de la relation,
même si je peux comprendre
l'intention de départ,
qui était, OK, on va écouter
cette jeunesse,
ses aspirations,
et d'ailleurs,
les débats ont été effectivement
très intéressants.
En même temps, pour reprendre
une expression qui lui est
familière au président Macron,
quelques mois après,
c'est retour
à la realpolitik,
parce que finalement,
c'est d'Etat à Etat qu'on discute.
Et qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
depuis quelques mois ?
C'est le retour,
dans les capitales africaines,
à la rencontre des présidents,
ces présidents qu'on ne jugeait
plus comme interlocuteurs valables
au sommet de Montpellier.
Tout ça m'interroge.
-La volonté d'émanciper,
d'émancipation, n'est pas
complètement,
je dirais, sincère
et elle n'empêche pas
les relations d'Etat à Etat.
Ca ne peut pas d'ailleurs
être effacé,
les relations d'Etat à Etat.
-Oui, bien sûr, mais je pense juste
qu'entre le discours et les actes
qu'on pose, il y a une dissonance.
Cette dissonance-là se situe
dans l'interstice de la réalité.
Une réalité où il faut bien
défendre les intérêts
des entreprises françaises,
où des intérêts sont en jeu,
et ça devient
très, très compliqué
de simplement dire OK,
on a entendu la jeunesse africaine,
on a entendu les critiques,
on va désormais ne plus traiter
avec certains pouvoirs
peut-être non démocratiques,
on va vraiment
être dans une relation
d'égalité
avec l'altérité africaine.
-Osvalde Lewat,
il y a un drame
que vit l'Afrique quand même,
il y en a plusieurs, hein,
évidemment,
avec le réchauffement climatique,
avec des gouvernements
pas vraiment démocratiques,
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire.
Il y a des fléaux
comme le paludisme,
on n'en parle jamais
d'ailleurs, pas assez,
mais qui sont réels
et il y a l'immigration aussi.
Comment on met fin
à cette immigration de masse,
de beaucoup d'Africains,
qui cherchent un eldorado
en Europe notamment
ou aux Etats-Unis ?
-Alors, avant d'arriver
à l'immigration,
je voulais souligner que l'Afrique
n'est pas le seul continent
qui vit de multiples drames.
Et c'est vrai
que, lorsqu'on les additionne
comme ça,
on a l'impression
que c'est les 7 plaies d'Egypte,
mais en Afrique, au-delà de tout
ce qu'on peut voir dans les médias,
il y a une qualité de vie,
une sociabilité.
-Bien sûr. Le sens
de la famille. Il y a plein de...
-Il y a... Il y a aussi
une vie que beaucoup,
notamment la diaspora,
recherchent à nouveau quand
ils rentrent vivre en Afrique.
-Bien sûr. Ou qui leur manque
quand ils ne sont plus en Afrique.
-Oui. Alors, comment on met fin
au drame de l'immigration ?
Plusieurs pistes
ont été explorées.
Je vais pas enfoncer
des portes ouvertes.
Mais tant que les gouvernements
en Afrique n'offriront pas
des conditions viables
à leur jeunesse,
ne seront pas
plus démocratiques, voilà...
-La clé,
c'est la démocratie ?
-Ne combattront pas
plus efficacement
la corruption,
ce sera très difficile
pour cette jeunesse,
qui aspire, qui a fait des études,
souvent, comme vous le savez,
ce ne sont pas les plus pauvres
qui immigrent,
ce sont ceux qui peuvent payer
un passeur, corrompre
des agents qui leur facilitent des
visas dans certaines ambassades.
Donc c'est le signe
que, aujourd'hui, en Afrique,
l'aspiration ultime,
c'est l'Europe, en fait.
Donc il faut à la fois que les
gouvernements, peut-être, soient
plus démocratiques et permettent
des conditions de vie meilleures
à leur population, mais aussi
que chacun, nous, notamment,
dans la société civile, qu'on
puisse reféconder les imaginaires.
-C'est quoi, reféconder
les imaginaires ? C'est très joli.
-C'est travailler chaque jour
à ce que cette jeunesse-là
se rende compte
qu'autour d'elle,
elle vit
dans des pays exceptionnels,
où il y a de la ressource,
des pays qui sont enviés,
et que chacun à son échelle
peut apporter quelque chose.
Donc il y a aussi
un attentisme qu'il faut combattre,
cet attentisme-là étant,
puisque l'Etat ne fait rien,
on va aller en Europe,
voir ailleurs,
voir si l'herbe est plus verte.
Je crois qu'il faut regarder
aussi attentivement
ce qu'on a,
nos potentialités,
et voir comment on peut
les développer.
C'est une dynamique globale.
Bien sûr qu'on attend beaucoup
de l'Etat,
mais je suis de celles
qui pensent
que chacun à son échelle,
quand on a une voix,
qu'on peut faire entendre,
il est important
que cette voix ait une résonance
auprès de ceux
qui n'en ont pas
et auprès de ceux qui s'imaginent
que l'Europe, c'est la panacée.
-Osvalde, vous êtes
franco-camerounaise.
C'est dur d'être
d'une double culture ?
-En ce qui me concerne, je parle
à l'échelle individuelle,
mes identités sont
vraiment miscibles
et je gère très bien
à la fois...
Je n'ai pas un pied en Afrique
et un pied en France,
j'ai 2 pieds en France
et 2 pieds en Afrique.
A chaque fois que je suis
sur l'un des continents,
dans l'un des univers,
les deux se retrouvent fécondés.
C'est un réel enrichissement.
Je crois que le problème
peut se pose peut-être
pour ceux qui viennent
de zones du monde minorées
et qui, par ailleurs, portent
une identité au moins
visible occidentale,
et qui se retrouvent
à la confluence
de différentes identités,
difficiles à assumer.
Alors, pour dire
les choses simplement,
ceux qui sont d'ici, de France,
qu'on renvoie sans cesse
à un ailleurs, dans lequel
ils ne se reconnaissent pas.
Ca devient beaucoup plus compliqué.
C'est Césaire qui disait
que l'universel est riche
de tous les particuliers.
Je trouve ça formidable.
Donc, moi, j'additionne
mes identités et ça crée en moi,
peut-être ça me donne
la force de créer...
-Vous êtes comme Romain Gary.
Il disait :
"Je suis un additionné."
-Ah, ça, c'est beau. Je pense
que je suis une additionnée
et je le revendique, oui.
-Il y a une singularité
au Cameroun,
par rapport à d'autres pays
qui ont été colonisés,
c'est les Allemands qui avaient
mis la main sur ce pays.
-1884, oui.
-Et après, il y a eu le congrès
de Berlin, donc les Allemands,
et puis les Allemands
ont perdu la guerre de 14-18,
et le pays est revenu
à la Société des Nations à l'époque
qui l'a donné à gérer à la fois aux
Anglais et, on voit le Cameroun là,
et aux Français.
Il faut le savoir,
quand on regarde
la carte du Cameroun,
les Français, c'était
plutôt la partie orientale,
les Anglais, plutôt
la partie occidentale,
c'est-à-dire vers le golfe
de Guinée et au nord,
c'était plutôt... il y avait encore
une résurgence allemande.
Donc c'est un pays qui a été
sous triple influence,
c'est pas simple,
quand même,
après, aujourd'hui,
de trouver
une unité à ce pays.
-Bah, je pense
que le Cameroun, aujourd'hui,
l'influence allemande
a vraiment disparu.
Je crois que les dernières
personnes qui parlaient allemand
ou qui avaient connu
la colonisation allemande
ne sont plus de ce monde.
C'est beaucoup plus,
on va dire,
les blocs francophones
et anglophones.
Une unité qui n'est pas simple
à trouver, mais qu'on essaie
quand même d'articuler. Certes,
dans le nord-ouest, sud-ouest,
il y a des tensions
extrêmement fortes,
pour dire le moins.
Et depuis 2016, c'est une zone
qui est entrée en rébellion.
Mais c'est un héritage colonial.
-De la colonisation.
-De la colonisation, puisque
ces populations-là étaient
au fond les mêmes
et elles ont été séparées
par la langue,
une langue française,
une langue anglaise.
Et cette partie-là du Cameroun
avait le choix
entre être rattachée
au Nigeria ou au Cameroun,
ils ont choisi le Cameroun
où ils avaient leur culture,
leurs traditions et leurs attaches.
Ce n'est pas simple à gérer,
mais les Camerounais
quand ils se retrouvent entre eux,
qu'ils soient du nord, du sud,
ils se sentent un,
ils se sentent proches, mais...
-Il y a un sentiment national ?
-Oui, extrêmement fort.
Il est même exacerbé
dans certains cas, oui.
-Assez orgueilleux, c'est ce
qu'on dit des Camerounais, non ?
-Forts en gueule, oui.
-D'accord.
Alors, vous avez
une particularité,
vous êtes une artiste
polyvalente, romancière
avec "Les Aquatiques", qui est
un magnifique roman, récompensé
par de nombreux prix en 2021.
Vous êtes également
photographe. Vous avez
exposé beaucoup de vos photos.
Là, on voit des photos
qui ont été prises
au Congo-Kinshasa.
Et vous êtes réalisatrice
de longs métrages.
"Une affaire de nègres", 2009,
"Sdérot, seconde classe",
en Israël.
C'était en 2011.
"Au-delà de la peine",
une histoire dans des prisons.
Vous êtes
une artiste engagée,
au sens sartrien du terme,
donc politique ?
-Sartre qui a dit :
"La nausée ne fait guère le poids
"devant un enfant
qui meurt de faim."
-Certes.
-Euh... Je crois que je suis...
J'aurais du mal
à faire de l'art pour l'art.
Et en même temps, je me sens
écartelée par deux polarités.
Celle de m'investir dans le beau,
ce que j'essaie de faire aussi,
un peu comme le décrit Nathaniel
Hawthorne dans "L'artiste du beau".
Et en même temps, il y a un côté
aussi hugolien chez moi,
qui est... l'utile,
loin de circonscrire
le beau, le sublime,
donc je suis très partagée
entre les deux.
J'oscille à chaque fois
entre ces deux polarités-là.
Est-ce que je suis engagée ?
C'est difficile de le dire,
ça sonne souvent militant
et moi, ça me gêne.
-Vous n'êtes pas militante.
-Non.
Je ne suis pas militante. A partir
du moment où on fait de l'art,
on s'engage.
Il n'y a pas d'art neutre.
-Parlez-nous du long métrage
que vous préparez
sur l'ANC, le mouvement
de lutte contre l'apartheid
avec Nelson Mandela
en Afrique du Sud.
-Alors, je fais
mon prochain documentaire,
qui va être diffusé sur plusieurs
chaînes de télévision,
donc Arte, Canal
et la télévision suisse,
c'est sur "Umkhonto we Sizwe", qui
veut dire la lance de la nation,
c'est la branche armée
de l'ANC
que Mandela avait initiée,
créée et commandée en 61.
Et c'est un film qui est aussi
un portrait en creux de Mandela,
un Mandela qui est un chef
de guerre, un commandant
d'une armée de guérilla.
-Qu'on connaît moins.
-Ce visage qu'on connaît moins
et je voulais sortir un peu
de cette vision très partiale,
très réécrite,
pacifiste de Mandela.
Il est devenu pacifiste,
Mandela, mais sur le tard.
Et je crois que le capitalisme
occidental a réécrit
cette image de Mandela.
-On a réécrit
l'histoire de Mandela.
-C'était mieux
de présenter ce papi à chemises
à fleurs, qu'il est devenu.
Mais celui qui s'est battu
pour la libération de son pays
et qui a été finalement contraint
de prendre les armes,
de prendre le maquis,
ce visage-là est
moins connu.
-C'est un guerrier.
-Ca rééquilibre le visage
de Mandela, très lisse.
Le film raconte aussi l'Afrique
du Sud d'aujourd'hui
à travers les anciens soldats
de la branche armée de Mandela
et le désenchantement
qui est le leur,
puisqu'ils se sont battus
pour un idéal
qui a été foulé au pied.
-Tout à l'heure, on parlait de
littérature, vous êtes romancière.
C'est qui, votre romancier
préféré ? En Afrique ?
-Ah. Alors, j'hésite
entre Chinua Achebe et Kourouma,
mais je pense
que c'est Kourouma.
-Alors, Chinua Achebe,
c'est un écrivain nigérian.
-Nigérian, tout à fait.
-Qui a toujours été en lutte
contre la corruption,
pas uniquement dans son pays,
mais le Nigeria est un pays
où la corruption est importante.
Pas assez connu en France,
il est de langue anglaise.
Et puis Kourouma, alors lui,
qui est de langue française,
d'origine... enfin, ivoirien.
"Allah n'est pas obligé"
sur des enfants soldats.
-"Le soleil des indépendances".
J'ai découvert
Kourouma adolescente.
Et sa façon irrévérencieuse
de triturer le français,
de le "malinkiser",
cet humour qu'il avait
dans ses textes,
cette liberté
m'a décomplexée
quand j'ai commencé
à penser à écrire.
Il est des auteurs qui m'ont donné
envie de devenir écrivaine.
-Merci,
Osvalde Lewat,
merci beaucoup.
-C'est moi,
"Uncatchable",
Alexandr Zhelanov
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA